in tonight's whatever happened to
segment the effort to expand exploration
for oil and gas here in the US long gone
are the days of long lines for gasoline
and skyrocketing fuel prices now America
appears to be on a path toward energy
independence and the top spot among the
world's oil producers tonight
correspondent Kristen Fisher tells us
where we are and where we may be going
we need an American first energy plant
president Trump has been a friend of the
fossil fuel industries ever since the
early days of his campaign on his fourth
day in office he signed an executive
order paving the way for the Keystone XL
pipeline
and now over a year into the job a new
study shows the u.s. is on track to be
the world's largest oil producer by 2023
thanks to the booming US oil shale
industry near record-setting crude
production the highest in almost 50
years and cuts in supply from current
leaders like Saudi Arabia and Russia but
it will also take at least that long
before the Keystone XL pipeline is
operational and any new offshore
drilling leases are approved the
pipeline continues to be plagued by
lawsuits from landowners and
environmentalists and while the company
behind the pipeline says it intends to
start construction next year it also
says that it hasn't made a final
decision to build it
as for offshore drilling in January
interior secretary Ryan Zinke announced
a plan to open virtually all US waters
to offshore oil drilling in five years
the proposal was instantly met with
widespread bipartisan opposition on both
the Atlantic and Pacific coasts and just
five days later after meeting with the
governor of Florida Secretary Zinke
pulled the politically important state
off the table saying quote that Florida
is unique and its coasts are heavily
reliant on tourism as an economic driver
that prompted governors from California
to Connecticut to say hey were unique
too at a hearing on Capitol Hill last
month the secretary himself seemed to
suggest that the entire West Coast could
also receive an exemption on the oil and
gas you should know off the coast of
Oregon Washington most of California
there are known reason no no no known
reason to stay to port the president's
plan Alaska and Maine every other
governor of States on the east and west
coast opposed it Brett Kristin thank you